forecast on 8 news now seems like mother
nature always throws in the monkey
wrench when you're traveling for the
holidays well today's pretty easy travel
weather skies are kind of a mix of blue
sky and some clouds out there that keep
streaming in from Southern California
temperatures are now up into the 50s
mostly 60 at Nellis 49 at Red Rock Kyle
Canyon cool at 36 degrees stage is set
for some snow up there as Lee Canyon
gets ready to open tomorrow that's right
opening day 36 Indian Springs that seems
a little cool I think they're closer to
upper 40s right now 51 in Pahrump 57 in
Mesquite 40s for Caliente seems right
ely's still pretty chilly at 28 40 for
Tonopah in Reno Laughlin's at 57 49 in
Searchlight so it's a little cool here
but a lot colder in other places around
the country more cold air continues to
move into the Pacific Northwest these
feels like temperatures over the
Northern Plains even below zero in
Bismarck Minneapolis feels like the 20's
notice the difference between Oklahoma
City that feels like 39 and Dallas Fort
Worth It Feels Like 76 degrees that's a
huge difference right now Nashville
feels like the 70s but not too far away
feels like 50s in Atlanta Washington D.C
in the mid 40s so there is some cool air
that's really streaming in but the
southern flow with that warm moist air
from the Gulf is really trying to push
northward and along it are some showers
and thunderstorms as well so it's really
the cold air fighting that warm air
along the jet stream today we will look
for showers and thunderstorms to
continue from the south east all the way
to the east coast and this low pressure
here just south of the Bay Area off the
central California coast still has some
moisture with it but we'll see how much
rain and snow really holds together as
it moves Inland later today and tonight
all this high level moisture these are
clouds just being pulled into Southern
California and streaming right through
southern Nevada Skies today so that's
what we're seeing and as that low moves
over with a little energy we might get a
sprinkle tonight in the valley but we're
really counting on a better chances of
some snow in the mountains tonight and
early tomorrow maybe even as low as 5
000 feet as that colder air comes in
with that low pressure 58 is what we're
looking for today and that's perfectly
normal for December 6th so can't
complain too much about the temperatures
the clouds will hold together in the
morning but after that they should clear
out to mostly sunny skies the system's
gone we'll wait for the next one which
is this weekend that one shows a little
more promise for some Valley showers
late Saturday night into the day on
Sunday and more chances for snow up in
the mountains as well we'll stay cool in
fact extra cool even down to the low 50s
next week John which means Mornings in
the 30s all right thanks